what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
another demon slayer video and this one
is very special because i'm going to be
going in depth into the man who crushed
muzon utterly defeated him in a second
and said the demon king crying to his
mommy so make sure to stay tuned for
this one because this is my favorite
character in the entire series and we
will be going into everything there is
to know about this dude including his
fight with muzon connection to tanjiro
his fight against upper moon one and
much more so stay tuned for that if you
do enjoy seeing these demonstrator
videos and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the demonstrator
within and smash that like button with
no mercy remember smashing that like
button is the strongest demonstrator
energy and passing is scared moves on
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos in all the hashira demon moons
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all the
character we are breaking down today is
yurichi tsugikuni the first breath style
user the user of the strongest breath
style sun breathing and the strongest
demons there in history you'll recognize
this dude as the really cool looking
samurai that demons keep seeing or
remembering when they look at tanjuro at
certain points in the story he has a
similar mark on his forehead to tanjura
especially when tenjiro's mark evolves
and he wears the exact same earrings
tundra wears all demons are scared of
this man because they were created using
muzon's blood and muzon still has ptsd
from their fight a recent example of
this character's appearance was when
daki suddenly saw a glimpse of him when
tundra was lecturing her about the
importance of life and she realized that
was a memory from muzon's blood not her
own but let's start from the beginning
when yurichi was born before his older
brother was jealous of him for being
someone who according to him received
the god's favor and burned everything
like the sun and before muzon was so
very scared of him yurichi was born as
the younger twin of michikatsu tugikuni
we know that yorichi was born centuries
ago more precisely over 480 years before
the current events of the anime we are
told that when the two were born twins
were viewed as inauspicious aka a bad
sign because they often caused
succession disputes yorichi was born
with his mark on his forehead rather
than being viewed as a good thing it was
viewed as disturbing and his father
declared that he would kill baby orichi
upon hearing this yorichi's mom got very
angry and didn't calm down until the
father agreed that he wouldn't kill
yorichi instead when he reached 10 years
old he'd be sent to a temple ironically
the jealous michikatsu was treated much
better as a child he got a better room
better clothes better education better
food and so on their upbringing was
completely different from ichikatsu's
perspective it looked like yurichi was
spoiled by their mother and couldn't
leave her side but we'll figure out
later that this was because she wasn't
well and yurichi was actually supporting
her even as a child kid michikatsu had
no idea though and peridorici for being
such a child and such a baby and that's
probably why he took what eventually
happened so much worse this whole time
he clearly thought he was superior to
little bro yorichi with the weird mark
on his face in his defense though
michikatsu was pretty nice when he
thought that his little brother was
inferior to him against his father's
will he would play in yorice's small
room with him and even though he
couldn't gift yurichi his own belongings
because his father would notice he did
make a flute for yurichi and give it as
a gift to him since he was a baby and as
a kid yurichi never smiled he didn't
even speak until he was seven so
everyone thought he was deaf it's funny
though one day he was watching his
brother practice swordsmanship and he
spoke completely coherently saying and i
quote my brother is your dream to become
the strongest samurai in the nation end
quote even though it was the first time
ichikatsu heard him speak he couldn't
help but notice that yorichi spoke so
smoothly michikatsu gasped and dropped
his sword yorichi went on to say that he
also wanted to be a samurai but as
mentioned his parents were gonna send
him to a temple when he reached 10 years
old wanting him to be a priest rather
than a samurai he was at this point
after speaking for the first time about
wanting to be a samurai like his brother
that 7 year old yorichi smiled which
disturbed michikatsu who'd never seen
him smile before michikatsu thought
yorichi had no shot since he was a boy
who clung to his mother's side all the
time while samurai need to be ready to
risk their lives however something drove
yorichi to keep trying he stuck around
during michikatsu's swordmanship
training saying he wanted to learn too
finally their father's vassal who was
teaching michikatsu the way of the sword
gave yorichi a practice sword for fun he
casually told yurichi how to hold the
sword and how to stand he told yorichi
to try to strike him and as we can
imagine he probably thought he was just
humoring the little yarichi who never
even held a sword before but this is
where yorici started to break
michikatsu's world apart yorichi was
insanely talented from the beginning no
matter how much michikatsu tried he
wasn't able to land a single blow on the
trainer but the inexperienced yorichi in
the blink of an eye landed four strikes
on the trainer and rendered him
unconscious so at seven years old he was
able to crush a hand-picked adult sword
expert he struck the man on the neck
chest stomach and leg no bones were
broken but he had fist sized lumps all
over his body you might think such
unbelievable natural talent would
encourage yarichi but quite the opposite
happened after embarrassing the teacher
he stopped saying he wanted to become a
samurai the feeling of hitting someone
was unbearable to him michikatsu
couldn't leave it alone though he needed
to know yorichi's secret to being so
strong and he kept questioning his
little brother about it yurichi finally
said and i quote before your opponent
attacks his lungs heave you just look
closely at the disposition of his bones
the contraction of his muscles and the
flow of his blood end quote as
michikatsu explained yorichi could see
inside the bodies of living creatures it
took him a while to understand that just
as he was born with the demonstrator
mark he was also born with special sight
as we find out this site is access to
the transparent world something that
only the most skilled demon slayers like
tanjiro gyome and so on gain access to
after a bunch of training and experience
andyorichi was born with it yorichi
possessed physical abilities that
complemented the site too here is where
the flip happened michigan to realize
that even though he had always pitied
yorichi his little brother was actually
far superior to him michikatsu was
obsessed with mastering the way of the
sword but yurichi was more interested in
playing board games or flying a kite
with his brother ichikatsu explains that
the way of the sword required pain and
suffering but talent had been recognized
in him and the harder he worked the
stronger he got but compared to a rare
child prodigy like yorichi he was like a
turtle that's how slow his progress
seemed while michikatsu's goal was to
become the number one swordsman samurai
yurichi who actually had the talent of a
number one looked bored when his brother
talked about swordsmanship toyorici the
way of the sword was less than child's
play even at seven years old eventually
it looked like the positions of the
brothers was being reversed the father
must have found out about yurichi's
skill enmichikatsu was really scared
that yurichi would inherit the house and
michikatsu would be forced into the
small room and then into the temple
where his dream of becoming a samurai
could never come true however just as
michikatsu was worrying about this
yorichi came by to let him know that
their mother died and he was heading off
to the temple early he came to say
goodbye not only did he not get in
michikatsu's way he even showed him he
was still carrying the flute that his
older brother had gifted to him yurichi
said he thinks of the flute as
michikatsu so even if they are apart it
would be like he's carrying michikatsu
with him yorichi says he will not lose
heart and will work diligently every day
even though to use michikatsu's words
the flute was junk that could only play
off pitch yurichi wrapped it in cloth
and kept it close to him like it was a
treasure he smiled looking at it just
the thought of the gift continued to
warm his heart yurichi bowed deeply to
his brother and then walked off with
hardly anything waving goodbye
michikatsu then found out from his
mother's journal that yurichi had sensed
that their father would make him heir
rather than michikatsu so he decided to
leave earlier than planned michikatsu
also found out that yurichi had known of
their mother's illness and approaching
death unlike the sheltered michikatsu
for years their mother had suffered
difficulties on the left side of her
body and then michikatsu realizes that
not only was yurichi not clinging to his
mother out of being spoiled while was in
fact supporting her the entire time
michikatsu was in fact the spoiled and
sheltered one all along instead of
feeling mad respect for yorichi at this
point as i do michikatsu is overwhelmed
by feelings of jealousy he tells us from
the bottom of his heart he hated yorichi
for being a genius although i don't
think michikatsu actually wanted this at
his core or at least not every part of
him he was overwhelmed by a sense of
inferiority and because of that he does
say that he begged for yorichi to die he
wished his little brother had never been
born since his existence defined the
laws of nature their father tried to
bring back yorichi but he wasn't at the
temple he had disappeared without a
trace so although michikatsu didn't know
what happened if kidnappers got him a
landslide or a bear he did receive his
wish in a way yorichi was gone and his
sense of inferiority and burning
jealousy abated he had a peaceful time
for 10 years until yurichi reappeared
one day but before we cover that let's
look at what yurichi was doing during
michikatsu's 10 years of peace we
discovered this from tanjuro's ancestral
memories that he inherits from sumiyoshi
who is the spitting image of tanjiro
yorichi shows up before tundra's
ancestor in adult form yorichi tells
umiyoshi that he's pleased they look
happy when yorichi sees people who are
happy it makes him happy he goes on to
say that the world holds much that is
beautiful it is a blessing simply to be
born into it he gives us some added
information about his childhood like
that his mother was a woman of deep
faith each day she prayed that strife
would disappear from this world and she
asked the sun deity to shine warmly upon
yurichi's death ears this is big because
tundra's dance of the fire god seems to
be celebrating this same sun deity and
as we know the dance is linked to sun
breathing which is the first and
strongest style that yurichi created
thus it seems very fitting that yurichi
is being associated with the sun deity
here it's revealed that his mother is
the one who made the iconic earrings
that tundra wears to this day as a charm
for yurichi and another nod to her
respect for the sun deity yurichi
explains that he regrets the fact that
his mother worried because he never
spoke and he also mentions that
michikatsu was a kind boy who was always
concerned about yurichi the day after
their father hit michikatsu and ordered
him not to pamper yorichi that's the day
he made and gave him that flute this is
partly why i don't believe mijikatsu
actually hated yorichi with all his
heart more accurately he hated himself
and was super hard on himself so much so
that he even left out parts of his own
backstory that would make him seem like
a better guy because he has such a low
view of himself michikatsu even told
yorichi that when he needed help he
could just blow the flute and michikatsu
would come right away the older brother
told him not to worry and smiled despite
his bruised and swollen face it's at
this point that yurichi reveals he was
supposed to go to the temple but he
didn't instead he wanted to run as hard
as he could under the infinite expanse
of the beautiful sky and yet after a
whole day and night he did not stop from
exhaustion this is another not yorichi's
extraordinary natural talent running a
marathon at a slower pace is hard let
alone running as hard as you can for a
whole day and night without even being
exhausted he eventually saw a girl that
was around his age in the mountains he
finds out that her family died in a
plague she's all alone and very lonely
so she came here to find tadpoles to
take home but she ends up freeing the
tadpoles from the bucket because she
feels sorry about separating them from
their families kidurichi offers to
accompany her home and notices that her
eyes are like obsidian the girl's name
was utta and they decide to live
together it's a very cute relationship
where as yurichi was stoic and a boy a
few words utah talked from morning to
evening from her yoricci learned that
people see the world in different ways
for instance she never even heard of
seeing through living bodies as if they
were transparent how weird is that
yurichi felt like he was estranged from
other people because he was like a kite
whose string had broken but uta held on
to his hand firmly ten years later they
married so that should be the same year
yarichi meets michikatsu again utah was
pregnant and it was nearly time for her
to give birth yurichi went to get a
midwife and he planned to return before
sunset however yurichi being the nice
guy he is gets sidetracked he helps an
old man with a bad heart who was rushing
to visit his son who had been fatally
wounded in battle he delivers the old
man to his son and decides he'll get the
midwife tomorrow he rushes home but
night has fallen when he arrives he sees
that someone has killed utta and their
child in her womb back to his
conversation with sumiyoshi orichi
explains that another person may not
hesitate to trample upon someone whose
life you value more than your own after
he found his wife like that yurichi was
in a daze and cradled the bodies for 10
days until a swordsman came in pursuit
of a demon you can tell he's an ancestor
of rengoku's the swordsman encouraged
urichi to mourn them properly through
prayer yurichi explains that he just
wanted to live a quiet life with his
family in a small house where they would
sleep side by side he would be close
enough to see the faces of his beloved
wife and child and close enough to reach
out and take their hands that would have
been enough for him he didn't need to be
the best to be rich or to be famous but
even that simple dream did not come true
because demons exist in the world so
after the funeral this is when yorici
becomes a demon slayer there were always
demon hunters but none of them used
breathing so yorichi taught them how to
do it the swordsmen called the hashira
were already strong and when they used
breathing along with the original sword
forms of flame wind water thunder and
stone they improved even further the
demon slayers learned to defeat demons
one after the next and yurichi mentions
that after demons killed his elder
brother subordinate he too became a
demon slayer and lent his strength to
the demon slayer core so let's quickly
jump back to michikatsu's backstory
since we just caught up with where we
left off there as michikatsu was
explaining he was living in peace for 10
years he married and had children in
that time every day was tranquil and
somewhat boring interesting that he used
somewhat boring there since i don't
think yurichi would have but still
tranquil is good and he might have meant
it in a good way the flow of time felt
extremely slow for him but then
everything changed when a demon attacked
the demon attacked where he and his men
had camped the time that stagnated up to
that point in his view had begun to move
again then who should appear but little
demon slaying bro yarichi to save
michikatsu from the demon even though
yurichi was talented before michikatsu
noticed that he was completely different
now he had mastered the sword the moment
michikatsu sawyurichi and how he could
easily defeat inhuman opponents his
serenity was destroyed his stomach again
began to burn with jealousy and hate
despite having saved michikatsu yorichi
still apologized for not arriving in
time to save his subordinates too
michikatsu observed that yorichi wasn't
just strong he was also a person of
faultless character michikatsu decided
that he'd make urichi strength and
swords kills his own no matter what the
cost he abandoned everything he
abandoned his home wife and children and
chose the path of a demon slayer same as
yurichi although yorichi taught people
sword and breathing techniques that a
single person could match him to suit
each person's skills and capabilities
yorichi changed the breathing technique
as he talked thus techniques derived
from sun breathing the first breath came
one after the other the number of marked
ones also increased and the power of the
demonstra core rose this is an important
detail because yes yurichi is scary
powerful on his own but beyond that he
improved the power of every other
demonstrator and the demonstra core as a
whole by teaching them breathing and by
increasing the number of marked ones who
only appear after an initial marked one
has like yorichi before long even
michikatsu manifested a mark identical
to yorichi's but in the end even
yurichi's own twin paled in comparison
to him and michikatsu couldn't learn sun
breathing but only a derivative later
named moon breathing michikatsu thought
he could catch up to yorichi if he
continued to train so he languished in
frustration until the marked ones began
dying one after the other as michikatsu
explained the mark gave people power in
exchange for their lifespan so this
golden era of demon slayers would soon
end michikatsu thought he had no future
left he had no time left for more
training so when muzon told him he could
carry on by becoming a demon he was
intrigued muzon told him if he became a
demon he could live on forever and focus
on mastering breathing techniques at the
same time muslim will get what he wants
to make a demon out of a swordsman who
uses breathing techniques from
michikatsu's perspective the path he had
hoped for had opened up he would be free
of all restrictions since he previously
said he'd catch up to yurichi at all
costs it doesn't come as a surprise that
he agreed to become a demon if yurichi
was a strong man of faultless character
michikatsu would become a man of no
character a monster and do whatever he
could to bridge the gap in power we'll
get to his eventual final confrontation
with yorichi in a bit but first let's
turn back to where we left off in
yorichi's backstory soon after
michikatsu became a demon slayer yorichi
found the demon's progenitor demon king
moves on himself in that moment yurichi
knew that he'd been born for the purpose
of defeating this man you could tell by
his expression that muzon was arrogant
at first and severely underestimated
what yorice was capable of and that
makes sense this is before yorichi
traumatized him so he'd probably never
even come close to being overpowered up
to this point but that was about to
change real quick first muzon said he
was no longer interested in swordsmen
who used breathing suggesting that he'd
already turned michikatsu into a demon
at that point and he had no need of yet
another demon-enhanced breath style user
muzon possessed fearsome speed and a
long reach as yurichi dodged he heard
the bamboo slicing and falling a
considerable distance behind him he
sensed that even a scratch would kill
him this is probably a reference to
muzon's blood being poisoned for human
beings for the first time in his life
yorichi actually felt a chill down his
spine but hilariously enough he still
outwardly maintained the same stoic
expression as always using his ability
to see the transparent world yorichi
could tell that muzon had seven hearts
and five brains and in that moment
yurichi said he completed his sword
forms we see him cut through muzon and
muzon's horrified what's happening
expression is absolutely priceless muzon
was further confused that his body
wasn't regenerating his head wouldn't
reconnect yurichi realized that his
bright red blade would work even against
muzon but instead of carrying on with
the attack ceaselessly yurichi asked
muzan what is the value of a life to you
muzon didn't respond his face just
turned dark red possibly due to anger
yorichi then looked at tamayo the demon
that was accompanying muzon and she
didn't move in to help muzon in fact
yurichi saw hope in her eyes as she
witnessed muzon losing yurichi finally
decided to finish off muzon and then
he'd turn to tamayo but when he took a
step toward muzon he heard the sound of
teeth grinding the next moment muzon's
body burst open with incredible force
out of 1 800 scattered pieces of muzon
yurichi cut a little more than 1 500
which is amazing but he says the
remaining pieces were too small they
would later recombine into a lump the
size of a head and allow muzon to
regenerate completely so not only was
muzon completely overpowered he straight
up knew that his only hope was running
away he'd become the prey even during
the night time tamayo cried and
collapsed saying yorichi almost did it
but muzon had overcome the weakness of
beheading tamayo said she wished muzon
was dead thinking it would activate
muzon's curse but surprisingly she was
fine she did not die yurichi eventually
calmed tamayo down and she explained
that muzon was the progenitor of the
demons and he would probably never show
his face to yarichi again literally the
best that the demons have to offer and
he doesn't even have the hope of being
able to become strong enough to take on
yorichi he needs to let nature and old
age beat him tamayo was relieved to be
free of muzon's control due to his
weakened state and agreed to help yuriji
in defeating muzon it was only then that
yorichi heard from the other demon
slayers including rangoku's ancestor
that his older brother had become a
demon instead of realizing that yorici
was their only shot of beating muzon the
other slayers turned against him because
he failed to defeat muzon and allow
tamiya to escape this is just so
ridiculous to me because literally
everyone else would have failed to
defeat muzon and done an even worse job
than yurichi but the whole helping
tamiya thing and his brother becoming a
demon was too much for them to handle
and they banished him from demon slaying
as a result samiyah wanted him to take
his own life which is ridiculous imagine
wanting the strongest demon player and
the only one capable of overpowering
muzon taken out of the picture the
master at the time was just six and
would not allow yorichi to take his own
life yurichi was very sorry to further
burden the young child who had just lost
his dad now back to yurichi explaining
all of this to sumiyoshi yurichi tells
him that he was born with special
strength for the purpose of defeating
muzon but he was lacking and in the end
he failed because of that many more
people will die and it pains him then
the daughter of sumiyoshi asks yurichi
for a hug she likes being lifted up high
so yarichi lifts her up and she laughs
yurichi can't help but cry when he sees
her smile he hugs her and continues to
cry sumyoshi's wife comes and tries to
cheer him up as well we saw in an
earlier flashback with yorichi and
sumiyoshi that yurichi washed their
child before so the mother could get
some sleep sumyoshi also thanked yurichi
for saving their lives before and adds
that if it weren't for yorichi his child
never would have been born in this light
even if he couldn't save everyone i'm
sure yorichi is glad he could at least
save that smiling child and that's
partly why he cries although him saving
sumiyoshi will eventually lead to
tanjuro and muzon's defeat even if it
didn't him saving sumiyoshi and his
family made a world of difference to
their lives which should not be
overlooked and that's just one family
orichi must have saved many more since
he was the star slayer of the
demonstrator core for a good while
anyway sumiyoshi told him that he'll
tell his children and grandchildren
about yorichi yorichi said that isn't
necessary yurichi told him that all
those who master their trade arrive at
the same place swordsman or charcoal
seller and that even if the times change
or the way to that place changes they
are certain to reach the same place
yurichi insisted he's not someone
special he couldn't protect anything
that was important to him and he was
unable to accomplish even one thing that
he should have in his life yurichi
viewed himself as a man without value
obviously urichi is being way too hard
on himself here but luckily he did go on
to pass the earrings and sun breathing
aka dance of the fire god down to that
family who eventually passed them all
the way down to tanjiro so even if
yurichi thinks he accomplished nothing
the story makes it clear that his
actions including saving this family
directly led to muzon's eventual defeat
not to mention the value of all the
people he saved and their descendants
getting to live full lives but before we
talk about muzon's eventual defeat let's
discuss yurichi's final meeting with his
brother michikatsu who at this point
goes by his demon name kokushibo
kukushibo in part took the demon deal
because it would give him time to get
stronger and escape an early death
caused by the mark thus he probably
thought yurichi died young too since he
had a mark as well but yurichi actually
lived to be an old man as kokushibo sees
as he's being overpowered by the hashira
and genya during their fight fukushibo
thinks this sensation of my composure
crumbling up from my feet is detestable
it brings me back memories from 400
years ago and of course he's talking
about when 400 years ago he confronted
odyurichi on the night of a red moon he
could not believe it when he saw it the
age and decrepit form of his little
brother was there over 60 years had
passed since they last met so yurichi
who had stayed human must have passed 80
years of age this means yorichi was born
over 480 years ago from the current
events of the main story and kokushibo
has been on the planet for over 480
years that's definitely a lot of time to
hone your craft anyways back to the
fight kokoshibo asked how he was still
alive since every marked one dies before
they turn 25 and then yoricci tells him
and i quote my sympathy is my brother
and quote here yorice is actually crying
for kokushibo now this seems crazy for
kokushibo kukushibo granted he has six
gross eyes but he also has eternal youth
and is nowhere near death so when he
sees this old and as he says ugly
creature that was once his little
brother pitying him it makes him pause
and reflect but interestingly enough he
doesn't get angry at old urichi since
this is a very important part of the
story i'll quote kokoshibo directly he
says and i quote even though 60 years
ago he had been such an eyesore the
voice calling me brother was terribly
hoarse my brother had never shown the
slightest emotion so at the sight of him
shedding tears something welled up in me
for the first time since birth end quote
again this is another example of
kokoshibo being more human and less evil
monster than he'd like to admit he goes
on to say he was confused at his own
unrest and decided he must kill the part
of him from when he was human yurichi
this old man of brittle flesh past his
prime represents this human part of him
and he decides he needs to take him down
he must cleave anyone who turns a sword
upon him even if it is his little
brother then kokoshibo says yorichi's
odd sentimentality disappeared the next
moment odyorichi got serious even though
he was old kokoshibo was very affected
by the aura of intimidation yurichi gave
off it was as if rocks had come to rest
on both of his shoulders kukushibo saw
no opening in the old man's stance urich
even told him here i come before he
attacked to give kokushibo the best
chance possible and still after
sacrificing everything to get to this
point kokushibo is no match yurichi cuts
him before kokoshibo even draws his
sword fukushima is angry wondering why
orichi was always a special one even
though he's marked he lived long
furthermore the technique urichi used
had speed and power no different from
when he was in his prime kokushibo's
memories and burning jealousy returned
because he felt like yorici alone was
outside the laws of this world he lived
receiving the favor of the gods upon
himself because of that kokushibo hates
him wants to kill him it's sort of
similar to the kane and abel story but
kokoshibo was never actually strong
enough to take his brother's life
furthermore kukushibo is certain that
yorichi's next blow will chop off his
head he calls yorichi sore technique
that even pressed muzon nothing less
than godly kukushibo feels unrest in
defeat like his insides might burst in
his mind the battle is over he already
lost but the next and final blow never
comes yorichi passes away from old age
while standing upright like a true
legend i honestly feel like yoriji's
first attack could have finished
kokushibo if he wanted it to but
kokoshibo thinks he was only saved
because yorichi's lifespan wasn't one
breath longer in all likelihood yorichi
was hesitant to kill his brother since
he cared deeply for him still and that's
why kokushibo survived instead of being
glad he survived though kokoshibo was
furious because of his long life as a
demon he had to live with that
humiliation for hundreds of years
kukushima thinks because urichi died an
honorable death won't visit him it's
interesting in that it seems like he
longs for an honorable death after
everything he's done it's like he wishes
that yurichi did finish him off back
then kukushima goes on to say now that
the greatest swordsman in the long
history of demon stairs has died he must
not lose he chose to continue winning
until to use his own words he became
ugly like this referring to his
repulsive six-sided demon form as that
final battle against the hashem genya
continues he also remembers a specific
moment he shared with yarichi during the
period they were both slayers which
katsu told yarichi that there are no
skilled warriors comparable to them an
important detail suggesting that
although yorichi was far superior
michikatsu was second best even before
becoming a demon but it just wasn't
enough for him michikatsu was telling
yurichi that the perfected techniques
will die out butyorichi the strongest
demon player in history said the two of
them aren't that great strong and humble
you gotta love it yurichi went on to say
that they are merely one fragment of
humankind's long long history he
believed that at that very moment those
who surpassed their talents are uttering
their first cries they may come to reach
the same place now of course yorichi was
heavily underestimating his own
specialness here but even if it wasn't
at that moment eventually people who
could work together to overcome muzon
were born he was just a few centuries
off still it's nice seeing how yarichi
smiled calmly and in a carefree way it's
clear that he was in a much better mood
when the two were working on the side of
good together he said to michikatsu and
i quote there is no need to worry we may
draw the curtain of life closed without
unease at any time does that not
exhilarate you brother end quote so in
stark contrast to kokushiba who
desperately wanted to be the strongest
and fear death yurichi believed that he
could go at any time and people would
eventually surpass him and this actually
made him feel really good the great
irony is that yurichi didn't care about
being the number one swordsman at all
and yet he was while kokushibo was
willing to sacrifice everything else to
become the number one swordsman and it
just wasn't enough he could never become
number one kokoshibo went on to say
after yurichi died that not only was no
one ever able to beat him but not a
single person was even able to harm him
in his entire life he went on to attack
urichi's body out of frustration and
then he saw that all this time yodish
was carrying the flu that michikatsu
gave him so many years ago the flute
that he associated with his big brother
and even though kokoshibo was saying he
hated his brother he was crying he cared
for his brother much more than he ever
wanted to admit he said yorichi was like
the unequaled son and all the human
beings around him have no path other
than yearning reaching out their hands
and writhing in agony until they become
ash despite giving up everything
kokoshibo could never reach the same
place yurichi did and although he said
that he hated yorichi and abandoned his
humanity he kept the flute on him for
the last 400 years as we saw when the
hashira and genya defeated him kukushibo
clearly had a more complicated
relationship with yorichi than one would
at first assume based on kokoshibo's
harsh retelling of his own backstory
it's revealed that after yorichi passed
on muzon and kokoshibo finished off
anyone else who knew sun breathing in
its forms and yet yurichi's techniques
remained because he passed them on
through sumiyoshi via the dance of the
fire god so that's yurichi's life he was
so strong that he crushed muzon in a
second or two made him run away like a
big frightened and emotionally scarred
for life baby and even as an old man he
was light years ahead of upper moon 1
and only lost because he passed on due
to old age nobody but old age could even
harm him and yet that's not where
yoricci's legacy dies he continues to
haunt muzon from beyond the grave and
his existence more than any other
contributes to muzon's eventual demise
we already looked at how tanjiro would
not be around today if yurichi hadn't
saved sumiyoshi and his family from a
demon so you can say that tanjiro being
alive is thanks to yorichi and so is the
fact that he learned sun breathing
obviously if not for yorichi there would
be no tanjiro and since tundra was the
first marked one of this generation the
others wouldn't awake demons earmarks
either their swords wouldn't turn bright
red and so on tundra is the key to
beating muzon and the others rally
behind him to get it done unlike the
golden age of demon slayers where they
ridiculously prefer to exile the best
fighters demonstrator shows the
importance of teamwork and how even
though no one individually surpassed
yurichi as a group that had help from
yurichi they were able to surpass him
together in the sense that they were
able to finish off muzon once and for
all one of the biggest reasons they were
able to do this in the first place is
because of tamiya's poison that kept
weakening muzon and even prevented his
body from dividing like it did before
against yorichi in order to escape and
guess what else now for yorichi freeing
her and inviting her to join the cause
then that circumstance never would have
come about either then there's the fact
that when muzon gets weak enough during
the final fight the wounds yaricci
inflicted upon him start showing up on
his body despite the fact that the fight
took place around 460 years ago we're
told muzon never recovered and yorichi
burnt muzon at a cellular level these
scars help the demon slayers of the
present see muzon's weak spots as tundra
thinks to himself even now 400 years
after his death yurichi is still showing
them the way it's interesting to see
during this fight how muzon remembers
his encounter with yurichi he says at
first yurichi seemed weak and didn't
show any drive fighting spirit hatred or
animosity and as you'll recall from the
tundra versus akaza fight that's because
he's reached that ultimate selfless
state that martial artists aspire to
reach muzon reveals that yorichi's
wounds to him would continue to burn his
flesh for hundreds of years like
sunlight so you can imagine muzon just
chilling having some tea and still
feeling the pain of that centuries old
fight it's not surprising that when
muzon says not even god or buddha would
have expected yurichi to be so strong
and capable muzon compares it to a
ridiculous myth and my favorite part he
goes on to say the real monster was him
and not me meaning yorichi the strongest
demons player in history is so
monstrously strong he makes the demon
king look like a human praise just
doesn't get much bigger than that you
know you're strong when the big bad boss
of the series views you as the real
monster and yeah even though muzon
repeatedly says that none of these guys
are comparable to yurichi yurichi laid
the groundwork so they wouldn't have to
be as strong as him individually to beat
muzon they just had to let tomoyo's
poison do its thing and work together
using the breathing styles that yurichi
started to drag out the fight until the
sun came up and that is pretty much it
for showing why muzon is so afraid not
only is yurichi dangerous when he's
fighting you one on one he continues to
haunt the demon king from the grave
through countless ways through the
burning of his flesh through the breath
styles he brought into being through
tundra his successor through tamayo and
her poison and in many other ways in the
end you can say that yurichi did defeat
muzon he just needed a little help from
his friends to finish him off once and
for all i hope you have a newfound
appreciation for my favorite character
if you tuned in to the end or if you
already loved him and recognized his
awesomeness i just hope you enjoyed
reliving all of his legendary exploits
yurichi is one of the best role models
ever and not because he was super strong
which he was but because as kokushibo
mentioned he had such a faultless
character anyways that is it for this
one if you did enjoy this video and want
to keep them coming chill toyorichi
within and slay that like button with no
mercy always remember smashing that like
button is urichi energy and passing is
scared moves on energy so choose wisely
if you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future demonstrator videos and
updates and while you wait for the next
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing demonstrator playlist that
includes videos on all the hashira demon
moons why everyone is afraid of tangero
and much more link to that is in the
description hashtag yurichi is the best
and until next time see ya space cowboys